if you have ever wondered how to
Leverage The Power of chat GPT the AI
language model to create compelling
content for your channel you are in the
right place in this video I will guide
you through the process of crafting
engaging YouTube videos with the help of
chatgpt's capabilities and some other AI
tools so let's dive in and unlock the
potential of AI assisted content
creation but before we begin let me tell
you guys that we have regular updates on
multiple technology videos so if you are
a tech geek in a continuation for the
latest technological Trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
YouTube channel and press that Bell icon
to never miss any updates from Simply
learn also accelerate your career in Ai
and ml with a comprehensive postgraduate
program in Ain machine learning gain
expertise in machine learning deep
learning NLP computer vision and
reinforcement learning you will receive
a prestigious certificate exclusive
alumni membership from Purdue and
hackathons and ask me anything sessions
by IBM with three capstones and 25 plus
industry projects using real data sets
from Twitter Uber and more you'll gain
practical experience master classes by
party faculty and IBM experts ensure
top-notch education simply learns job
assist help you get noticed by Leading
companies live sessions on AI trends
like chat Deputy generative Ai and
explainable AI this program covers
statistics python supervised and
unsupervised learning NLP neural network
computer vision Keras tensorflow and
many more such skills so enroll now and
unlock exciting Ai and ml opportunities
the link is in the description box below
Also let's take a minute to hear from
our Learners who have experienced
massive success in their careers you
need to keep updating your skills on a
regular basis no matter what level
you're at I recently completed the
professional certificate program in Ai
and machine learning from Simply learn
in partnership with Purdue University
the course material was comprehensive
and the faculty was extremely
experienced The Faculty was able to
adjust their teaching style in order to
cater to the overall skill set of the
class in the rapidly evolving world of
technology it's important to keep up
Skilling for every working professional
stay relevant continue learning now
let's dive in and see how chat GPT can
help you make great videos for your
YouTube channel opener created chat GPT
an advanced language model powered by
artificial intelligence it's designed to
understand you provide helpful responses
and adapt to your writing style whether
you are a content creator a student or
anyone seeking assistance chat GPT is
your go-to companion it uses vast
knowledge to help you with creativity
problem solving and learning so let's
move to chatgpt and see what we can do
to make YouTube videos so here we are in
chat GPT now the first thing we are
going to do is we are going to see how
to use shared GPT so before you use the
LGBT you should know how to give prompts
to chat GPT so chat GPT can get you
valuable content but you should know how
to give the prompts so here we'll start
with a thank you so we'll write over
here
thank you for helping me today fine so
let's see the response of chat GPT
so here you can see it says you're
welcome and
I'm glad that I could assist you so here
you can see
kgpt is asking us if we have any more
questions or not so let's define what we
actually want chat GPT to do so we'll
write over here hi
I want to create
a new YouTube channel so let's say we
are starting our YouTube channel fine
now we'll say I want to create a new
YouTube channel where
I want to discuss facts
mostly okay so we'll write over here
mostly related
to programming languages
so the first thing you should keep in
mind is what you want chat GP to do
chatgpt won't give you the full video
for specificity check GPT 3 won't so we
are not using the plus version of charge
GPT so we'll in this video I'll tell you
how to create a complete video only with
AI not just at GPT but we are going to
use another tool which will help us
create a video completely so here in
chatgpt what we will do is we'll ask
shared GPT to provide us the script fine
the script for a video so here you can
see we I have written over here mostly
related to programming languages so I'll
write over here
I want
to
create a video
on facts about programming fine the
length of the video
will be let's say four minutes for now
because for now we are not going to use
that much of script I will use three
effects fine so write a script
for the same
and present so let's wait for chat gpt's
answer to this question so here you can
see we have a scripture gpts writing a
script so we you can see we have a
script which starts with welcome back
programming enthusiasts in today's video
we'll dive into the fascinating world of
programming languages and explore three
insightful facts that will blow your
mind so grab your favorite coding
beverage and let's get started so here
you can see
we have three different facts right so
we have first one is we have during
completeness and the second one is so
trick programming languages and the
third one is non-deterministic
programming languages
fine
so let's change it let's ask chargpt to
give us three historical facts about
programming use three
Oracle facts about
programming fine so let's see if we are
getting a new script or not so yeah here
you can see we have a new revised script
with three historical programming facts
fine so here you can see the first fact
we have is Photon the Pioneer first fact
takes us back to late 1950s when the
world's first high-level programming
language was born Fortran so Fortran is
basically the world's first high level
programming languages and then we have
the birth of c and the third one we have
is the rise of world wide web and
JavaScript so JavaScript was basically
created by Brandon Ike in 1995 and since
then JavaScript is
being used by most of the developers out
there right so here are the three facts
we have now here you can see we have
host written over here the host will say
if you found these historical fin site
fascinating and want to delve deeper
deeper into the world of programming be
sure to hit that subscribe button and
stay tuned for more wow it can write a
complete YouTube script right for
YouTube specifically similarly you can
create videos for different purposes not
just YouTube but you can create videos
for your blogs and different different
purposes fine so here you can see we
have a script right now the script is
quite long right so I'll write over here
concise it in how many words you want
let's say 600 words it's a random number
600 by the way so we'll concise we'll
ask jdbt to concise it in 600 words so
as I mentioned earlier you should be
clear with your prompts to chat GPT
chargpt will do it fine
so here you can see we have a new script
the revised script the concise version
basic basically
so here you can see we have another
three packs the same three facts but
this time they are concised to 600 words
so here you can see it didn't make too
much of change it didn't made any
click slight change right not too much
of change because I guess the other
script is also 600 words around so I'll
reduce it a bit more and let's see
I'll say
reduce this
script to
300 words fine so we are going to create
a small video because you can create a
long version but this time we are going
to show you by creating a short version
The Script everything will remain the
same it's just that you have to create a
long version you can add 10 facts or
anything you want to create right we can
also create shots using chatgpt that
we'll see in some other video fine so
here you can see and here we have a
complete script now that's done we have
a complete script from here till here so
here you can see we have written over
here feel free to customize and add your
personal touch to the script and it's
basically check if it is telling us that
we can customize this script and give
some Personality yeah we can do it right
we can personalize it we can customize
it according to our needs so for now
what we are going to do is we are going
to take this complete script only we are
not going to customize it because it
will take more time so what we are going
to do is we are going to move this to
this website it's V Dot I V Dot IO is
another
AI tool it will help us create projects
video projects so this tool is
completely free not completely free but
this tool is free to use as well fine
you can create projects you can create
videos from this tool so here you can
see once you go to the v.io website you
just have to sign in and just click on
create a project so now what we are
going to do is we are going to create a
video that too by only using the chat
gpt's script fine
so we are not going to upload any video
from there so we'll just cut this this
part now here you can see we have
different options we have settings where
we will go to settings we can change the
layout we can also create YouTube shots
here fine so it's already you so here we
are going to create a YouTube video so
that's why we have used this YouTube 16
ratio 9 aspect ratio so here you can see
this clean audio it comes in the
upgraded version of this feed dot IO so
we are using the free version the trial
version basically for now so here you
can see we have media and then we have
audio
and then we have
subtitles text elements templates we
have a number of things right so here
you can see in elements we have
different sound waves we have we can use
them right so it totally depends on us
how we want to do it whatever we want we
just have to grab it from here we have
to paste it in the video and I'll show
you wait a minute so here you can see
we'll go to media and
Media or audio whatever thing you want
so just click Text to Speech so here you
can see
we have different voices over here so if
I use Ashley female so we have to
put the Thousand characters so in free
version we can only use thousand
characters only
so if we wanted more than that we just
have to upgrade fine so for now we are
going to use the free version only
so we'll write over here this
and
then we have to use this just a second
we will copy it from here we'll paste it
here
and here we are going to
get a second
Dot and yeah so here we have the second
fact and then we have the
third Factor as well fine
so we'll write over here we'll copy it
from here
will paste it now we have only 116
characters remaining and if you want to
create the whole video
so we'll just copy this from here and
just paste it here so we have
uh like cross the limit 78 characters
over the limit so we'll remove some part
more captivating content happy coding
and exploring programming history fine
so we are done with the complete script
we have three effects we have the intro
part and the outer part now just preview
it welcome back
today we'll explore three captivity
so it looks fine we can just change the
voice from here we can use Brendan's
voice as well
Now preview it welcome back
today we'll explore tree captivating and
we can change the English from here as
well so here you can see we have
different languages present right we
have English we have
okay we have French we have
indonesianized islandic we have kannada
we have Lao so basically almost all the
languages are here so for now what we
are going to do is we are going to keep
it English
and we can also search for it
so here you can see we have English
yeah right we are using U.S English for
now
so add to project
fine so it will generate the voiceover
so for now we are just adding the
voiceover fine
so here you can see we have the
voiceover let's play it once today we'll
explore a free captivating historical
facts about programming languages that
shape the programming landscape so here
you can see
if I take it back from that so it it
starts from Welcome Back only fine now
so you guys can hear it right the audio
is nice so it's just a text to speech
right we have the voiceover now for our
video for a complete video let's check
towards the end if it's there or not
putting and exploring programming
history yeah it's there right so you
guys can hear the voice and now the next
thing we are going to do is we are going
to add some media over here so we want
it to look good so basically
here you can see we have different stock
videos so let's just add some stock
videos
and we have to identify where we you
have to use which video fine
we'll
right over here coding and here you can
see we have
a number of videos most of them are
basically
free with the paid version we are not
using the paid version so we are going
to use this in this video only fine
so we have to add it and
just here you can see the stock footage
okay so here you can see we have the gap
for adding this video now
now you can see the video is here
and we can also use the animation effect
the corners the opacity rotation and
there are different video editing
options basically we can use the clean
audio which is again a
Plus
upgraded version feature so here you can
see we have audio we can control the
audio and everything
we can also use remove this green green
screen right remove a color from our
video a particular color we can remove
so this video is this long we'll just
play it once
today we'll explore a three captivating
historical facts facts about programming
languages that shape the programming
landscape
let's Dive In
in the late 1950s I'd
so here you can see we have this video
what we are going to do is we are going
to welcome back
today we'll explore three captivating
historical facts about programming
languages that shape the programming
landscape okay so till here we are going
to use this video and we are just
starting our video so we need something
like Welcome to our Channel welcome to
this welcome and subscribe and all this
so what we can do is we can add some
text over here fine
and we'll just use this headline title
oh no we are not going to use the
headline title
we are going to delete it from here we
are going to use Simple Text
and just click on it
just change here write your welcome
to our
Channel
fine
and that's it
we can
okay this video is moving for now
we can use this we can move this we can
keep it in the center
increase the size
in the background the coding video will
keep on going fine we'll use it until
here
okay so we are done with this and we can
use some sort of animations and all so
we are going to use animation over here
so fade we can use slide right slide
left
we can use wave
okay so we are going to use wave
and come back
today we'll explore three captivating
historical facts about programming
languages that sheet the programming
landscape so it's looking nice right
here you can see we have this today
we'll explore three captivating
historical facts about programming
languages that shape the programming
landscape fine now the next thing we
need is we need another video another
stock video fine so we'll again go back
to Media
it's taking time for my laptop but if
you have a good laptop a nice working
laptop so it will work totally fine
there will be no issues so I'll use this
video I'll drag it and drop it
so the drag and drop I guess it's not
working
so just click on ADD video from here
and you can basically learn how to do
editing through this software alone
because here you can see we have
different options we have ai doing
everything for us right everything we
are getting in place just with this one
AI tool and so this is how AI is helping
us fine so from here the new
video will come
okay so it's a long video 20 second
video
and here you can see the transition
cheap landscape let's Dive In
in the late 19th okay so the first fact
will come here right so we want some
what we can say text again
so we'll write over here or we can use
the typewriter fine for the first one
we'll delete the simple one
and we'll use the
typewriter one fine
we just have to put it in place
just keep it short
and just change the caption what we was
the first caption
Port run fine
portra on the pioneer
just write it over here
change the color to white
just take it a little back
resize it
place it according to your needs and
yeah it's almost done so animations we
can use
okay this time we are going to use fall
fine
then it will say Fortran the Pioneer it
will come over here and from here the
fact will start in the late 1950s IBM
introduced Fortran the world's first
high-level programming language
it simplified scientific and engineering
computations
no
so here you can see we have two videos
right for next two effects we can add
two more videos or we can just use these
videos again and again now let me tell
you the simplest way of adding videos
through this software so what we have to
do is we need stock videos right so if
you need stock videos for your uh videos
like stock footages for your videos so
what you can do is you can go to
different websites where the stock
footages are free you can just download
them and you can just
use them here in V Dot IO so once you
are done just click on done and Export
the file so here you can see we have
export video option right so this is how
we can create a complete YouTube video
uh we are not creating one right now
because it will take a lot of time for
us to create now what you have to do is
you have to just go to Media
and add some stock footages you can here
you can see you can upload a file in
this as well so what you have to do is
you have to upload a file use this file
over here and then what you have to do
is you have to use these what we can say
headings to express different facts so
this is how we can use chat GPT to
create a complete video fine
now once you are done with everything
click on done name your project if you
want to you can use any like on title
project I have used you can create any
videos once you export the video it will
give you certain options so here for now
our video length is one minute eight
seconds fine 44 MB is the size and
our video is short right V Dot IO gives
you thousand characters for free so
that's what you can use we have used
those thousand characters and once you
are done with this V Dot IO will allow
you to export that particular file so
creating a YouTube video using different
AI tools is easier right you don't have
to waste so much of time so if we
conclude it all you need is you need to
be sure what you want in your video and
that's it go to what we can say chat GPT
and then ask for the script charge GPT
will write the script for you go to
vid.io vid.io will create the video for
you that's it you can download it from
here even you can download the video
from here click on this download button
and it will download the video the one
thing will be you will get a watermark
so if you want to remove the watermark
you have to use the upgraded version of
V Dot IO fine
so it's the easiest thing to do right so
here you can see the video as far as we
made so
yeah you can see it
welcome back
today we'll explore three captivating
historical so this video so this video
right now is not working completely fine
because of the laptops we are using so
if you are using the software you need a
little high-end laptop fine and so
that's a wrap for this video I hope you
guys must have got a good idea about how
to use chat gbt for video creation fine
you can create videos on your own with
the help of cat gbt and vid.io try
making one and let us know in the
comment section if you are able to make
one completely fine
so don't forget to check the AI and ml
course we have discussed in the starting
the link is present in the description
box below so that's all for this video
guys thank you so much for being here
well we'll see you next time until then
keep learning and stay tuned to Simply
learn thank you
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign